okay vitamin D is low vitamin D another
sign of sirs yes it's not in the
literature so I have to always preface
that I get very iffy about vitamin D
because a lot of the vitamin D I think
they use certain ingredients that are
similar to rat poison I know vitamin D
has been super highly advocated for
during covid so I am a little bit more
cautious about it there might be
incorrect numbers that we are chasing
for vitamin D levels that's one I could
share a study with you I'll give it to
you afterward but it says that actually
the optimal levels like 25 and that
people were reading the paper wrong what
I have seen is a lot of my clients again
they're the sickest of the carnivore
Community their vitamin D is low so a
lot of them will do the D3 K2 5000 10
000 IUS it barely moves the needle when
they go through the service protocol
they take the VIP there has been a
strong association with when the VIP
regulates the msh goes up and all the
symptoms start reducing their vitamin D
goes up naturally